foreign
mom can you hear I don't want you to
hear what it is
[Music]
this is heavy how heavy do you get
ah yeah so the most hurtful thing I've
been told because I I thought about this
for a while
uh it wasn't told to me it was written
to me my mom sent me an email she sent
an email to everybody so it doesn't feel
like it should hurt as much if everybody
got the brunt end of the stick but she
told all of us that
she no longer wants to be um
sorry
I never shared like this
she doesn't want to be
our mom anymore
uh she's no longer anybody's mother
she's no longer anybody's sister
she's just decided not to be anybody's
family
so
actually when I have spoken about this
I'm usually a lot stronger explaining
what happened so
I don't know why I'm crying at this
point when I don't usually cry when I
tell people about this so you know life
has been super good after she left I
think it honestly brought
the family together a closer
relationship and more deeper
relationship with my with my aunties and
my siblings and my stepdad and so it
there's like a silver lining to all of
it recently
my ex-boyfriend called me on the phone
one day when we are still together and
told me that he hated me and that I was
a low value woman
um because of my past because of things
that I've done
and I never thought I could be hurt by
such simple words it caused me to change
my identity so drastically I shaved my
head my hair is just finally growing out
um from that hurt I just had to get away
from it and shed the person I was and
become someone different because that
that one thing hurt me so bad I just
like lost myself in that pain and I'm
finally starting to come out of that
pain and coming into myself and feeling
my strength again
um and I can still really feel the hurt
of those words
I would say it's not necessarily what
I've been told more around the action so
like when I was younger I used to have
the worst allergies ever right and so
and I was also left-handed so it was
like almost like this like awkward
double whammy I was getting and you know
like when you were in like grade school
you guys were sitting like these little
cubes and so like sometimes my elbow
would like end up brushing up against my
classmate and or I would end up sneezing
and slowly at surely over time it was
like my desk was an island and the rest
of the
the little pod That was supposed to be
was maybe like another five feet away
from me in the moment I hated life I
will admit that but in retrospect
it was needed and because at this point
like it's allowed me to just be that
much stronger of a person or it's like I
know that it's really not going to be
that bad because
this too shall pass I just need to keep
pushing my rock up the hill sure it
sucks today but
eventually I picked my rock and for me
my today my rock is playing guitar and
so every day I'm just playing more
guitar trying to get better trying to
find my sound and if you could find that
honestly what more could you ask for
uh the time that the gynecologist told
me that I lost my child
I felt that literally like like if the
cat was ripping my heart out of me it
was a disturbing feeling that I never
thought that I would felt in the most
painful thing about it is what that I
was holding my dad's hand and I saw my
dad cry with me for the last very first
time
probably
I don't deserve such a nice kid
I have two kids and somebody told me
that I don't deserve they are too good
for me
to be a father
because I have a
I had a quite a
background sometimes was a little shaky
but this was the most hurtful
I felt sorry for this person who said
that why would you say something like
this
you know it's like you have to be very
very angry inside
to say something like this do you still
carry that hurt with you like does it
still no no no no okay no
no I don't because it would it would
destroy my my peace of mind
[Music]
and it would have destroyed me from
inside
I repeat the question what's the most
painful hurtful thing you've been told
all right so I'm gonna share this just
because I think that I wanna
I want people to love themselves despite
what they may have been told that could
have made them hate themselves I was
told by my mother that I should not have
been born she repeated
that to me throughout my whole life
um
I don't remember how old I was when she
first told me that she should have
aborted me
I love my life so much that
I don't understand how anybody else
could not love me
but I also don't know if it's because
she doesn't love me or because she
didn't want to be a mother I don't think
it's the truth talking I think it's just
her pain and I've never said it like
this out loud before so no one has ever
asked me this question
uh it would be
a while back like 10 years ago
um it's actually my first girlfriend
ever
um we were
outside my house and she had said you're
not enough
for me and that kind of
Gonna Hurt You Know
broke me I was I was like what like it's
15 16 and she told me that just
um
not a lie every once in a while I'm in
my bed thinking about it hurts again
makes me think maybe I'm still not
enough for someone
have you had a relationship since
I have not
no I just go learn to love myself before
I could love others but I think about it
um the thing at this time that's coming
to mind is a time when I was a freshman
in high school I was
um there was my high school was about 45
minutes away and so I was in the car
with a bunch of other boys from where I
lived and I was picked on a walk so I
was a lot smaller all the other kids
knew each other I was the new kid that's
always forced inside the middle you know
they played punching games anyways at
the end of the car ride I was crying
this one time and one of the other guys
who I thought was like you know my
friend said hey I'm really sorry like
you know like I promise like I won't do
that again two days later he was up to
the same thing and it really just I
don't know struck me really hard
um and so
yeah you know that was a very tough time
in my life and
um but I look back on that time being
able to experience stuff like that and
overcome it it teaches a lot of
resilience in a person an adult life you
need a lot of resilience you know to
really uh make a impact on this world
and I feel like um that's something I
really want to do
oh God I feel like I do know it's like
not even saying somebody said to me
people just like there's been a few
people who've asked like what's wrong
with me and like if I'm on drugs before
there's like one specific time at a
party somebody was like what are you on
and like would not give it up they just
would not stop asking like I was
drinking because it was like a party but
like barely and I just was like being
normal and they were like what like what
are you on like no tell me like
seriously and I was just like
just just normal just like being myself
I don't know really makes you feel
like an outcast when people literally
ask like what's wrong with you and when
you think you're just normal I think
it's also like what people like about me
too so it's like I've learned to like
love that about myself and not like hate
myself for it which has been very like
good for me I guess yeah
my dad has told me he's really
disappointed in me when I was really
young
um and that kind of hurt you know
hearing that you disappointed your
father at 14 kind of hurts
um he just looked me up and down and
said I'm really disappointed in you and
I just went back inside
and I went to bed because that was kind
of rough for me
oh the most hurtful thing I do remember
very vividly when I was probably about
14 or 15. walking home from school one
day and running into a girlfriend and
her boyfriend as I as we walked by he
stopped to talk to me you know and I
kind of thought oh you know I'm being
acknowledged or something like kind of a
big deal but then he said just wanted to
know how did you get so ugly and it was
just something that did actually stick
with me over the years it was defining
in a way that uh it made me you know it
sort of contributed who I am I I've
always been sort of one to uh
um make a little bit of extra effort
although you can't tell now but I'm like
old but um
that's just what popped into my head
I was in kitten boarding school I was in
the seventh grade the seventh grade
teacher was the principal and we were in
class and he said to me
Michael there's no conceit in your
family I'm going oh whoa he's just
you've got it all
I didn't know I was conceited
he told me I was and so that's when I
started questioning
that part of me I was still developing
and I was in a boarding school and
I had a bad
my background was tumultuous to say the
least when I was five years old my
mother's second husband molested me I
blurted it out to my uncle that what my
father made me do they call my mother my
mother divorced him several years later
she married another man he molested I
was in the third grade and so that's
when I get taken out of my family as or
my wife my mother and put in boarding
school because my grandmother knew that
it was going down and she didn't know it
my mother's an alcoholic her husbands
were alcoholics
she was indifferent to me generally
I was the product of her first marriage
being dragged along in her second
marriage and her third marriage and I
don't think she was happy because I was
the cause of the breakup of her second
marriage and I think she really was in
love with this guy she had three kids by
him after I revealed what he was doing
they got divorced
I think that really turned her off to me
in general like I just don't like this
kid so boarding school was a good place
for me I went into boarding school came
out of boarding school went to high
school for one year so I joined the Navy
after 10 years and he was another moment
I'm gay in the 10th year of my
enlistment I got outed
and the off the office of neighbor Naval
intelligence oh and I came after me
threatened me and I didn't want to get
kicked out but I they had me I couldn't
re-enlist so I just said okay you won't
see me around when my list is up in
three months and I did my GED I got out
got my bachelor's degree in nursing and
then about 10 years ago I retired so I
am now an RN registered nurse no retired
nurse
you've been through a lot how are you
able to like push through it I don't
know you know I've often asked myself
that question I was a I was running
scared but I was determined not to fall
see I've got a lot of blessings in my
life I'm 82 years old I have no medical
problems I have no financial problems
which is all just to say what a awesome
life I live
I think the most painful thing I was
ever told was when I was five years old
my aunt pulled me aside and she told me
I was never going to amount to anything
that I was going to be a hoe I was going
to have multiple men I was going to be a
failure I wasn't gonna do anything that
meant anything
and that really stuck with me for a
really really long time I think it was
part of the reason why I try so hard to
make change now because I'm trying to
prove her wrong I don't hate anyone but
she she I'm like this close to hating
this woman but I also feel like I kind
of want to thank her for being so evil
because now I only see the world with
kindness and I try to make sure like I
insemplify that and everything in my
life and I feel like with time I've like
developed myself and I'm able to finally
like give people that kindness that I
wish I had when I was five so
[Music]
hi everyone
um I know I've been gone for a while but
I'm back and I just want to say thank
you for watching this episode I love you
all and I'll see you next time